Hi, my name is Dr.
Alana Natas, and
today we're going
to go over the
introduction to
ophthalmic disorders.
This is going to
review both anatomy
and basic
ophthalmic concepts,
as well as clinical
ophthalmology.
So the first part of
the ocular anatomy
that we're going to
go over is the cornea,
which is the thin
anterior portion
of the eyeball. It
protects all of the
intraocular contents,
and it's responsible
for 75% of the
refractive power of the
eye, which is basically
how we see. So
when we do LASIK
surgery, if you click
on the link, you'll
see LASIK procedure.
This is what we
alter to basically
get you out
of eyeglasses.
It's avascular. It
receives nutrition from
the tear film and the
aqueous humor. It has
a very, very rich
sensory innervation. So
that's why eyelashes
when they get in the
eye are so painful.
And it has five layers.
The top is epithelium
followed by Bowman's
layer, the stroma,
decimase membrane and the
endothelium, which is
the innermost layer.
Next is the
conjunctiva. The
conjunctiva is
basically a thin,
clear covering that
goes over the white
part of the eye and
the inside lining of
the eyelids. It's called
the bulbar conjunctiva
on the white of the
eye and the palpibal
conjunctiva on the
inner eyelid apart.
It contains goblet
cells that create
mucus and also accessory
lacrimal glands that
give us more moisture
in the tear film.
The next part is the
eyelids. They protect
the ocular surface from
mechanical injury by
blinking. They also
contain your eyelashes.
They have meibomian
glands also. These are
oil glands that are
these little dots that
you can sometimes see
if you look really,
really close in the
mirror, and they produce
the lipid part of
your tear film. These
are very important
because the lipid allows
the tear film to stay
stabilized on your
eye over the course
of the day. There are
also sebaceous glands
in the eyelid as well.
We have the nasal
lacrimal system, which
is where the tears
drain into. They drain
into the punctum,
which is this little
opening right medial
to the inner part of
the eye. You have
an upper and a lower
punctum that drains
into the canaliculus
and down into the
nasal lacrimal system.
That's why when
you're crying or if
you're tearing a lot,
you can sometimes feel
like you're sniffling
because all those
tears are going
down into your nose.
In the back of the
eye or the posterior
segment or the fundus,
which you see a picture
of here, we have the
retina. The retina
is a heavily pigmented
neural tissue.
It's a very orange or
yellow-orange color.
It contains their
photosector cells, which
is how we see our rods
and cones. The macula,
which is the most
central part of the
retina, and the fovea,
which is the center
part of the macula, is
where our very, very
fine vision comes from.
We also can see the
optic nerve, which
looks like a big round
disc there where many
of the arteries and
veins come out to feed
the retinal tissue.
And then we have
the vitreous, which
is this clear gelatinous
substance made
of collagen and water
that sits between
the lens inside
the eye, as well
as the in between
lens and the retina.
We have the iris in
the front part of
the eye, which is
usually the colored
part. So brown,
green, hazel, blue.
It's a thin
contractile diaphragm,
which allows our
pupils to become
larger or smaller.
So the pupils meios
when they become
smaller and they're
midriatic when
they become larger.
The color depends
on the melanocyte
density. And the
ciliary body is also
located in the
front part of the
eye. It surrounds
the lens and vitreous
base and it creates
aqueous fluid.
And then we have
the choroid,
which is a highly
vascular layer
between the retina
and the sclera.
We also have the
lens, which is a very
important focusing
part of the eye. It
accounts for one third
of the refractive
power of the eye.
Imagine it almost like
a camera lens, and
it's surrounded 360
degrees by tiny
zonules, which are the
little ligaments that
allow the lens to round
up and flatten out,
which gives us our
focusing ability
called accommodation.
As we get older,
towards 40 and up, we
start to lose this
ability of accommodation,
and that's why we
tend to need reading
glasses to see things
better up close.
Opacity of the
crystalline lens is called
a cataract, which
I'm sure many of you
are familiar with.
We see here a very,
very white cataract.
Sometimes it doesn't
look like this, but
this is a very good
example of that where
you can just see it
head-on without even
using a microscope.
Most commonly, it is
age-related in nature,
but many different
drugs can lead to
early cataract
formation, such as
corticosteroids, topical
glaucoma medications.
Trauma to the eye
can induce cataract
formation relatively
rapidly, and
uncontrolled diabetes
is another common
cause of cataract
formation as well.
The definitive treatment
for cataracts is
cataract extraction
with intraocular lens
implantation, and
I included a link
there for you guys to
watch if you do want
to watch a video of
cataract surgery. It's
really awesome because
we can take care
of this opacity that's
developed by removing
the cataract and
replacing it with a
clear lens implant
that's measured for
the patient's eye to
help them see better.
Another aspect of
the anatomy is the
sclera, which is an
opaque fibrous protective
outer layer of the
eye. It's a very
firm tissue that
creates the strong wall
of the eye that the
intraocular muscles
insert into. Sometimes
as we get older,
or the tissue can
thin out and it may
look blue or gray.
And it actually is
continuous with the
dura mater and cornea.
Our extracular muscles,
we have several
of them listed here.
They work together
in the horizontal,
vertical, and torsional
axes. So for the
horizontal muscles, we
have the medial and
lateral ******. The
vertical muscles,
superior and inferior
******. And oblique
muscles, the superior
and inferior obliques.
So the obliques
work on intorsion and
extorsion, and they're
controlled by cranial
nerve 4 and 3.
And the superior
******, inferior
******, and
medial ****** are
controlled by
cranial nerve 3,
lateral ******,
cranial nerve 6.
So, and then you
just have some
basic terms here.
Synergis are muscles
that move in the
same direction.
Yoke muscles
that are pairs of
muscles in opposite
eyes that move
the eyes in the
same direction.
And strabismus is an
improper alignment
of the eyes, not
so unlike this
chameleon here.
Often this is seen in
pediatrics where one
eye may turn in or
out in a child, and
we can treat this
with various methods
such as patching,
atropine therapy,
and even surgery.
So the basic
approach to the eye
patient is like
any other patient
that you'll see
in practice.
What's the visual
complaint? When did it
start? Did they add
a recent history of
trauma, surgery,
illness? Was there
exposure to some sort
of infection? We check
vision, extraocular
muscles, pupils,
intraocular pressure.
We do an external exam,
look at the skin
around the eye. Then we
do a slit lamp exam,
which is our special
microscope that we use
in ophthalmology to get
a closer look at the
smaller tissues of the
eye and then do ancillary
testing as needed.
This is just a picture
of the slit lamp.
It comes very, very
close to the patient's
eye, and it gives us
a cross-section as
well as other views of
the eye with different
lenses that we might
use in the office.
I know our neuro teachers
probably are giving
you a huge review of
the visual pathway.
So this is just a basic,
for my standpoint,
light comes into
the eye. It's
processed by
the optic nerve,
goes through the
optic chiasm,
optic tract, lateral
geniculate body to the
optic radiation, and
then see the occipital
lobe, which is how we
see. So any blockage
in that pathway, as it
would make sense, would
cause a decrease or
a distortion or no
vision at all, depending
on how severe it is.
These are various visual
field defects. Also,
I know this is being
covered more in your
neuroclasses, but one
of the things that
pops up a lot on boards,
whether or not it's
general boards or
ophthalmology boards, is
bitemporal heminopia,
which we can see
on the left side
of the screen. And
that's typically from
something compressing
the optic chiasm
from below. So it
can be a pituitary
tumor, which is the
most common, or
other tumors as well.
Um, we have the
pupillomotor pathway,
um, which is just
listed here for
your information.
I know it's
covered in depth in
your neuroclasses.
Our pupils are important
to assess on our
ophthalmic exam because
we want to make sure
that they're reactive
to light on their own
and they have a consensual
response. Um, this
is important because
it shows us that the
pupillomotor pathway
is intact, any defects
in this pathway can
show up as a problem
with the pupils. So
you may have a picture
here where one pupil
is very dilated and one
pupil is very constricted,
and we have to kind
of sort out why that
is. So in ophthalmology,
the term that we use
commonly for this
is called a relative
afferent pupillary defect
or an RAPD. And that
is because in this
situation, you would
normally get a consensual
light reflex. So if
you shine a light in
the right eye, the left
eye pupil is actually
going to constrict
as well. Any defect
along that pathway would
cause an RIPD. So that
would mean that if
you shine a light in
the right eye, the left
eye is not reacting.
So this is important
just to give us an
idea that there's
something either going on
within the back of
the or in the brain.
You can also have something
called anisochorea,
where the pupils
are of unequal size.
They may be meiotic,
but also of unequal
size, or they may be
dilated of unequal size.
Horner's syndrome is
a big thing that's
tested in terms of pupil
problems. So the triad
is ptosis, meiosis,
and anhidrosis. The
patient may have a
small pupil and on the
same size have same
side, have a droopy upper
lid. They may have a
lack of sweating on
the forehead above
the affected eye. And
there's different
ideologies for this. It can
be something called
preganglionic, which
extends anywhere from
the hypothalamus to the
superior cervical
ganglion, which is
usually from ******,
though it can be from a
vertebral artery dissection
and cervical disc
disease. And it can
also originate from a
postganglionic source.
And the most common
and severe thing that
we worry about here
is internal carotid
artery dissection, which
can not only cause
****** and this syndrome,
but other problems as
well. So any person
that you suspect has
Horner's syndrome
should have a neural
workup to make sure that
there's nothing that
we're missing here.
Just some more pupils.
There's something
called a Hutchinson's
pupil, where
there's a unilaterally
dilated poorly
reactive patient pupil
and a comatose patient.
And this is usually
due to um, um,
uncle herniation
or displacement
of the hippocampal
gyrus, which
entraps the third
cranial nerve.
There's also other
ocular muscle disorders,
chronic, chronic
progressive external
ophthalmoplegia
or CPEO, which is
a mitochondrial
disease. Um, it can be
associated with
something called Kieran
-Seres syndrome, where
there's a retinal
pigment degeneration
and heart block.
Myasthenia gravis
is probably the most
common ocular muscle
disorder that'll
pop up in life and
also on the boards,
where there's weakness
of the voluntary
muscles due to
autoimmunity up to the
motor end plate.
So basically, the
acetylcholine receptor
have antibodies that
are floating around
and blocking them.
So the most common
thing is patients just
have severe weakness.
Usually, you see it's
fatigability. So
patients might say, I
wake up in the morning
and things are okay,
and as the day goes
on, I'm just so weak.
90% of these patients
with myasthenia do
have eye symptoms.
so they might have
eye fatigue, they
might have ptosis, they
might have diplopia,
they might have
limitation of their
extraocular movement.
And there are some
patients that have
only ocular myasthenia
where this is limited
just to the eyes.
The diagnosis is
typically done by a
neurologist but usually
they use something
called a tensilon test
which is something
that's injected
through the IV, and it's
acetylcholinesterase
inhibitor, so it
prolongs the action of
acetylcholine, and it
produces a stronger
muscle contraction
in these patients.
Another way of testing
this is testing
for the acetylcholine
receptor antibodies
for binding, blocking,
and modulating.
There's other ocular
muscle disorders
that we might see
too, such as thyroid
-related ophthalmopathy.
You may have seen
commercials for
thyroid eye disease.
typically what happens
here is there is
deposition of these
autoimmune particles within
the tissue surrounding
the orbit. And you
get a lot of congestion
in the orbit and
proptosis where the
eyes are pushed forward.
So the eyelids become
retracted, as you see
in the picture here
on the left-hand side.
The patients can
have dry eye redness
and pain, restriction
of motility. They
even can have optic
nerve compression.
And the tricky thing
with this is that
they may actually
have normal thyroid
levels, but they
typically do have the
antibodies for thyroid
disease present.
Another ocular
muscle disorder
is myotonic dystrophy.
It is autosomal
dominant from chromosome
19. And these patients
have myotonia of
the peripheral muscles.
They can have very
interesting looking
cataracts called
Christmas tree cataracts,
which we see here.
There's other vascular
optic neuropathies.
The two main ones
that we need to know
about are something
called anterior
ischemic optic neuropathy,
or AION, and posterior
ischemic optic
neuropathy, or PION.
Anterior ischemic
optic neuropathy has to
do with an infarct of
the optic nerve head
just posterior to
the lamina curbrosa,
and this causes an
acute painless vision
loss. So patients
come in saying, I just
lost vision, but
there's no opinion. They
typically do have an
RAPD. They typically
do have some finding
of the optic nerve
on exam where there
might be optic disc
edema, which you can
kind of see in the
pictures down below. It
looks like there's this
fuzziness surrounding
the optic nerve.
And what we worry
about in AION is if
it's inflammatory
because that's something
called arteritic
ION or giant cell
arteritis or temporal
arteritis. And the
issue with this is
that it affects medium
to large size
vessels. And there can
be vision loss in one
eye and very acute
vision loss to follow
that in the other
eye. So it has to
be detected early.
The non-artertic
ischemic optic
neuropathy is
typically associated
with microvascular
disease.
Posterior ischemic
optic neuropathy has a
lot to do with
decreased blood flow and
oxygenation into the
intraorbital optic nerve.
So more on giant
cell arteritis.
This is tested a lot
both on ophthalmic
and regular boards.
So again, it's
an inflammatory
vasculopathy
affecting medium to
large size vessels.
Typically, the presentation
is an older male
or female, older
than 55. They come in
complaining of a headache
on one side, decreased
vision. They may have
double vision. They
may also have scalp
tenderness. They may get
jaw pain or pain or
fatigue ability of the
jaw when they're chewing.
They may have new
onset pain or arthritis
like pain in their
shoulders or their hip
area. And when you do
an exam, you sometimes
can see an RIPD on
that side. You sometimes
can see a fuzzy
looking or a pale or
edematous optic nerve on
that side. And you may
actually feel a decreased
pulsation of the
temporal artery on that
side compared to the
other side. So if you're
suspecting this, the
typical workup is to
get blood work first
and you may see an
elevated ESR or an
erythrocyte sedimentation
rate, a CRP, which is
a C-reactive protein.
You may also see a low
hematocrit, and you
may also see elevated
platelet levels or
thrombocytosis. Any
elevation in these with a
corresponding clinical
picture that's suspicious
for temporal arteritis
should have a workup
with a rheumatology
partner and also will
likely need a temporal
artery biopsy to
confirm the diagnosis.
We usually start steroids
for these patients,
oral or IV, depending
on how severe the
presentation is, to prevent
basically vision loss
in the fellow eye
because whatever vision
loss has occurred in
the presenting eye may
not be retrievable,
but we want to make sure
that the inflammation
doesn't continue on
within the body and
go on to affect the
vision in the other eye.
There's also, in
terms of other optic
neuropathy, is something
called idiopathic
intracranial hypertension
or pseudotumor, which
you see here a very
edematous optic nerve
with normal neuroimaging
and normal CSF
findings if you were
to do a lumbar puncture
and look at the cell
types in the CSF,
the cerebral spinal
fluid. Usually this is
in female patients
around age 33 or younger.
It is associated
with obesity. These
patients typically have
really severe headaches,
nausea, vomiting,
optic disc edema. They
may have something
called transient visual
obscurations where
they go from a sitting
to standing position
or a laying down to
a sitting position
and they lose vision
and then it comes back.
They may have something
called pulsatile
tinnitus as well, where
they hear almost like
a whooshing sound
in their ears along
with the vision loss.
So it can be due to
durosinous thrombosis.
It can be due to
use of steroids. It
can be due to use of
oral contraceptives,
vitamin A toxicity,
and iso-retinoin
toxicity.
The treatment
is an escalating
treatment. So if
these patients have no
vision loss, we
just basically treat
their headaches
and weight loss is
advised, which
typically helps a lot.
Mild vision loss, we do
give something called
acetazolamide, which
is a diuretic, which
helps to decrease
the symptoms as well
as weight loss. And
if the vision loss is
very, very advanced,
these patients may need
serial lumbar puncture
and something called
a lumboparitoneal
shunt or an LP shunt.
Optic neuritis
is another optic
neuropathy to be
aware of. It's
inflammation of
the optic nerve.
It's the most common
optic neuropathy
in patients younger
than 45 years
old. And these patients
may also present
with acute unilateral
vision loss,
and it may recover
spontaneously.
They typically
have pain and eye
movement. They typically
do have an RAPD
with a visual field
defect. The optic
nerve can appeal
normal or swollen.
These patients can
have something called
UTOF's phenomenon where
they have worsening
of their symptoms
with heat or exercise.
And the thing that
we need to remember
with optic neuritis
is that 30% of these
patients can develop
MS within four
years and 38% within
10 years. So this is
not something that
even if it goes away,
we're like, okay,
we're done. We can
move on. We always
have to be watching
these patients
neurologically as well.
So that was our basically
basic science
ophthalmology.
We're going to move
on to more clinical
ophthalmology and what
we would typically see
for patients who come
into the ER or the office
and things that pop
up on boards as well.
So ocular disease,
the thing to be aware
of is it can be
isolated to one or both
eyes, and it can be
related to systemic
conditions, which we'll
see going forward.
So big thing here
is the red eye. This
comes in to urgent
care, comes into the
ER, comes into the
office. It's everywhere,
and there's many
different cause.
So from outside to
in, the red eyelids.
You can have something
called blepharitis,
which is simply
dryness and irritation
of the eyelids
where the lash line
is, and that can cause
dry eye symptoms.
You can have the stye,
which is basically
a clogging of the oil
glands on the external
part of the eyelid.
You can have a
chalazin, which is
almost like a stye that's
just deeper within
the eyelid, but it can
be a little bit harder
to treat. Typically,
these have to be
incised and drained.
And you can have
something called preceptal
cellulitis, where
you get a cellulitis
of the tissue
surrounding the eye.
Another part of a red
eyelid situation is
something called ******
zoster ophthalmicus,
where you can have a
****** zoster infection
involving the V1
distribution of the
face. So you can see this
rash along the forehead
and along the nose
on that side. And it
can typically is very
red and it has other
lesions that scab over
similar to chicken
pox. And you can also
have something that's
orbital cellulitis
where the preceptal
cellulitis picture that
you see in the lower
here has progressed to
go behind the globe.
And these are usually
children who get this,
but they present
with very, very tense
eyelids. It's almost
impossible to open the
eyelid. And when you do
a CT scan, you see that
there's just a ton
of pus and fluid
surrounding the orbital
structures, and usually
that has to be treated
with IV antibiotics.
So back to ******
osteophthalmicus, this
is a big one that
basically all practitioners
have to be aware
of what it looks
like. comes into the
ER, comes into the
office, comes into
urgent care. It's a
unilateral painful skin
rash and a dermatonal
distribution of the
trigeminal nerve.
It presents with vesicles
on the skin, which
typically crust and
heal within two to six
weeks. And if a patient
has Hutchinson's side
where there's skin
lesions at the tip side
or root of the nose,
there's a strong, strong
predictor of ocular
involvement because
this is where the
nasoaciliary nerve travels.
So the issue with
this is that this is
not just having
vesicles on the eyelid.
These patients can
actually have a ******
zoster infection
of their eyeball
itself, which can
sometimes be very, very
difficult to
treat. It typically
presents an adult older
than 60 years old,
and it's basically
a reactivation of
latent varicella
zoster virus in the
sensory spine or
cerebral ganglia.
It can be more
prevalent in
immunosuppressed
patients.
It's one of the reasons
why shingles vaccine
is highly recommended
for patients over
60 years old. And they
may have a prodromal
period where they have
fever, they just don't
feel very well, and
they can have headache
and eye pain and a
skin rash pre-existing
the other ocular signs
that we might see.
So we do a very careful
eye exam for these
patients, and we
typically give them oral
antivirals for at
least 10 days, although
some patients may need
IV therapy. For the
skin lesions, we
usually give a topical
antibiotic ointment.
Some patients might need
steroids, either
topical, oral, or IV. And
unfortunately, this
condition can cause severe
neuropathic pain,
and they may end up
needing other treatments
to manage that pain.
Moving forward, there's
also the red eyeballs.
So we did the red
eyelids. Now there's
red eyeballs. There's
many different kinds
of conjunctivitis or
pink eye. It can be
allergic, contact,
inflammatory, infectious.
We can also have a
redness just because
of something called
subconjunctival hemorrhage,
where a small
blood vessel on the
surface of the eye
bursts. And it can look
very, very red, but
it goes away on its
own, and it's really
of not a consequence.
And the lower picture
here is just a
picture of what's called
episcleritis, where
it's an inflammation
of the deeper layers
of the eye rather
than the conjunctiva.
So many, many
different ideologies
of conjunctivitis
or pinkeye.
Viral is the most
common cause.
Usually adenovirus is
what we see, especially
this time of year.
We have like a watery
discharge with that,
eyelid swelling. You
can get ******
infections that can cause
just a conjunctivitis
picture. These are
typically treated
symptomatically as they do
resolve on their own,
although some patients
may need antiviral
treatments. We can have
allergic conjunctivitis,
which is treated
usually with topical
allergy medications
or oral bacterial
conjunctivitis. Usually,
this is seen more in
children. We get a pus,
mucousy kind of
discharge, and it usually
lasts a week to 10
days, and these are
definitely treated with
antibiotic eye drops.
Gonorrhea is actually
something that we
always look out for
because it can actually
become so severe,
it can perforate the
cornea. So these
patients are typically
given a dose of
intramuscular ceftriaxone.
And believe it
or not, COVID can
present with pinkeye
as well. So things
to be aware of as
you see all these
patients with pinkeye
in your careers.
Scleritis basically
involves an inflammation
of the sclera. So it's
very different than
conjunctivitis.
Conjunctivitis, you can
see going back here,
it's kind of like a
lightish pink color. It
can be diffusely red,
but when you get scleritis
or even episcleritis,
which is just the
layer of tissue
above the sclera, it's
this deeper red, almost
like burgundy red
that you see. And it's
a very, very painful
experience for the
patients. It could be
autoimmune, infectious.
It can be related to
uveitis as well, which
is just a general
inflammation in the eye.
You can also get a
red eyeball from a
corneal ulcer, which
you can see on the
top picture there.
That round grayish ring
on the cornea is
an ulcer. And the
white stuff that you
see in the eye is
actually fibrin. It's
called a hypopion. So
this is a really
severe infection that
basically all these
white cells have
just accumulated in
the front of the eye.
The bottom picture
shows something
called endophthalmitis,
which is an
infection that has
spread beyond the cornea
into all of the
layers of the eye.
You can't even see
the pupil there.
Typically, these
patients do need surgery
or injections of
medication into the eye.
Another cause of a
red eye is something
called acute angle
closure glaucoma. This is
a big one for the boards,
both in ophthalmology
and on regular
medical boards, too.
these are patients
that come in with acute
eye pain they say things
got blurry they were
maybe in a dark room
maybe watching a movie
the pain is really
really severe they have
nausea vomiting the eye
is red they have blurry
vision the cornea
looks a little cloudy
and they have a fixed
mid dilated pupil what
happens here is the
space between the cornea
which is the clear outer
covering of the eye
and the iris which is
the colored part of
the eye becomes so
narrow that the aqueous
fluid that normally
flows within the eye to
maintain the eye pressure
gets basically trapped
and so there's nowhere
for the fluid to
go the pressure builds
up and up and up and up
and the patient can
actually be at risk of
vision loss because if
the pressure goes up
really high it can choke
off the blood supply
to the optic nerve so
these patients that
come in the immediate
treatment is to give
eye drops to try to bring
down the eye pressure.
And sometimes IV
acetazolamide and mannitol
can bring down the
eye pressure as well.
And the definitive
treatment is something
called a laser
peripheral iridotomy,
where we make a small
opening in the iris
to allow a new conduit
for the fluid in
the eye to flow through
and to increase the
space between the
cornea and the iris.
So once again, looking at
this acute angle closure,
not conjunctivitis,
a lot of different
kinds of redness
in the eyes.
Definitely
good to be able
to differentiate the two.
Causes of decreased
vision can be as simple
as refractive error.
So needing glasses or
contact lenses, some
patients are myopic,
meaning they're nearsighted.
Some patients are
hyperopic, meaning
they're farsighted. Some
patients have astigmatism,
which just has
to do with the curvature
of the eye. There's
degenerative condition
called keratoconus,
where the front part
of the cornea is shaped
more like a cone rather
than a round ball,
which you can see on
the top image there.
And there's also
conditions called
corneal dystrophies,
where there may be
particles or
particulate matter that
is deposited in the
cornea from birth,
which sometimes
causes no problem
with vision, although
many of them do.
You can see that on
the bottom left there.
And then, of course,
we talked about
cataracts as a major
cause of decreased
vision in many patients
as we get older.
Another cause of
decreased vision is
glaucoma. So we
talked about acute
angle closure
glaucoma. There's also
something called
open angle glaucoma.
Whatever the cause
of glaucoma, it's
an optic neuropathy.
So what it does
is it hurts the
optic nerve tissue.
So on the top left
there, you see there's
a picture of an optic
nerve that looks very
healthy, which is in
picture A and picture
B shows that it's
excavated. So all of that
nerve tissue is gone
because of damage
from glaucoma, which
can cause irreversible
vision loss. There's
also retinal vascular
occlusions that can
occur, which are basically
like mini strokes
to the eye. There
could be branch retinal
artery occlusions. They
could have central
retinal vein inclusions,
which can have a
lot of bleeding and
cause a lot of edema
in the back of the eye.
And of course,
there can also be
retinal detachments,
which can cause
vision loss and
decreased vision.
Another cause of decreased
vision is macular
degeneration or
age-related macular
degeneration or AMD.
There's two different
types of AMD, dry and
wet. The dry kind is
more common, and it's
typically associated
with these little
yellowish-orange
deposits in the back of
the eye called drusen.
For many of these
patients with mild
disease, we follow them.
We recommend taking
different kinds of
antioxidant vitamins.
And many of them do
stabilize. It's very
uncommon for them to
transition over to wet
AMD from dry AMD,
although it can happen.
Wet AMD has to do
with the growth of new
blood vessels in
the back of the eye
and the retina. They
grow through the
retina, they're very
weak and they can cause
bleeding. So these
patients actually
end up getting
injections of medication
in the back of the eye
to cause regression
of those new blood
vessels that grew.
And it also causes
a little bit
of dissipation
of the blood that
in the back of
the eye as well.
And we've come a
long, long way in
terms of the different
amount of therapies
that we have for
treating wet AMD,
although it is
still considered the
more severe type of
AMD for patients.
Retinal detachments is
a big one to remember
in terms of real life
and also your boards.
The typical symptoms
that patients will
have is flashes and
floaters. So they'll
say, I'm seeing these
a lot of big and small
dots in my vision.
They may say that they
see one big curtain
hanging down and blocking
their vision. And
they also typically
complain of seeing a
camera flash of light
every time they close
their eyes or in the
dark. And this is
because the retina is
essentially peeling off
from the back of the eye.
These patients can
have the retinal
detachments spontaneously,
but it can happen in
patients who are very
nearsighted. It can
happen after eye surgery.
It can happen after
trauma. Some patients,
unfortunately,
have a family history
of retinal detachment.
Severe diabetic eye
disease can cause
retinal detachments
as well. And the
management for this,
depending on the size
of the retinal
attachment, it might be
able to be treated
in the office with a
laser. But oftentimes,
these patients need
a vitrectomy surgery
where a retina
surgeon will go in and
physically tack the
retina back down
using a fluid, a gas,
or a combination of
the two with laser.
Another cause of
intraocular retinal's
attachment can be
due to mass. This
is certainly less
common than the typical
retinal tear
retinal's attachment,
which you can see
in the picture here.
But the classical
thing that you'll see,
at least in ophthalmic
boards, is there is
an unfortunate predominance
of ocular melanoma
that presents as a
retinal detachment.
So this is a
uveal melanoma.
You can see on the
color image here, it's
like this dark structure
that's pushing the
retina off. And then
we have a sonogram of
the eye that's showing
this very, very large
growth in the black
and white image there.
um another thing to be
on the lookout um is
something called
leukocoria so that means
we all know that we
have red reflex when
we check the back of
the eye we sometimes
have red reflex in photos
leukocoria basically
means that there's
a white reflex and
in peds this is a big
deal because we want
we want to rule out
that there's nothing
called retinoblastoma
lurking in the back of
the eye there's other
causes of a white
pupil such as disorders
of fetal vasculature
um sometimes if
there's a long-standing
retinal detachment it
can look whitish when
you shine a light
in the eye cases of
endophthalmitis might
look whitish as well
and also something
called a colaboma but
in kids you want to
make sure that you're
looking for that nice
red reflex in both
eyes there's also
other causes of vision
loss such as traumatic
optic neuropathy
the ischemic optic
neuropathies,
which we talked
about before,
central retinal artery
occlusion, which you
can see on the bottom
image there, where
basically the whole
retina has turned white
because that central
retinal artery has been
occluded. It's a horrible
****** to the eye.
Central retinal
vein occlusion can
occur, and also
something called vitreous
hemorrhage, where
there can be
bleeding into the
vitreous, which makes
the vision very,
very, very blurry.
Acute eye pain.
You can have something
towards the corneal
abrasion or a scratch
on the cornea,
which can actually be
very, very painful.
That can heal on
its own typically
in a few days, or
it may unfortunately
go on to develop a
corneal infection
or an ulcer. So
we usually treat
these patients
with antibiotics.
Dry eye can also
cause eye pain. Acute
angle glaucoma, we
know, can also cause eye
pain. Iratus, which
is inflammation in the
eye, can also cause eye
pain. And of course,
trauma to the eye
can cause eye pain.
So corneal abrasion
can be in a
history of just a
very small scratch to
the eye, a fingernail,
a paper cut,
can be seen in
contact lens wear.
There's an unfortunate
condition called
recurrent erosion syndrome
where the abrasions
can occur spontaneously,
and it may
even occur upon eye
opening in the morning.
The treatment is
typically antibiotic
drops and ointment. we
do not give anesthetic
eye drops for this
as a treatment.
Anesthetic eye drops
used chronically
can actually cause
something called a
corneal melt. And
that's what we see on
the bottom image
there. Basically, the
whole cornea has
melted away and the
iris is protruding
through. That's very,
very bad. We never
want to see that.
Chronic eye pain
can be due to dry
eye. It can be to
uveitis, which is
inflammation in the eye,
migraine, sinusitis,
scleritis,
episcleritis as well.
On the top image there,
you see a picture
of uveitis where
there's inflammation in
the front part of
the eye. And you see
these little dots on
the back part of the
cornea called keratoc
precipitates or KPs.
This is typically
treated with steroids,
both topically,
sometimes ****** as well.
So the uvea is the
iris, celibriate,
and choroid,
as we saw from
the first part
of the lecture.
Uveitis is an
inflammation of any of
these parts or a
combination of them.
It may only occur
once and be completely
idiopathic. And
what you see are all
these little white
blood cells floating
on the slit lamp,
which is this image
that you see here.
It can be infectious.
It can be
autoimmune, which is
usually the more
common type.
So we always want to
ask a patient about
their history. Do
they have any history
of autoimmune
conditions? Do they have
any exposure to unusual
infectious diseases?
We do a comprehensive
ophthalmic
exam, and we may partner
with a rheumatologist
and infectious a
disease specialist,
depending on the
disease course with
these patients. And
like we just talked
about, the typical
treatment is steroids.
Usually, eye drops are
sufficient for most
patients, but they may
require subcontractable
injections or
intraocular injections of
steroid as well as
oral steroids as well.
These patients have a
similar presentation
to those episcleritis
patients that they
have a dull, achy
pain. They're sensitive
to light, blurry
vision. Some patients
do actually complain
of floaters as well.
Always good to
check the retina in
these patients
because sometimes
uveitis can
present in the back
of the eye and not
just the front.
Double vision. Double
vision, the most
common cause of that
is strabismus, which we
typically see in
children, although you
can't see it in adults
because strokes,
trauma can all cause
problems with the extraocular
muscles. So you
can see in that top
image there, this
unfortunate patient has
up palsy where
he cannot bring
his eye in. He
can only bring
his eye out on
the right side.
That causes severe
double vision in
that case. And
usually these patients
may require something
called a prism
eyeglass or
strabismus surgery to
strengthen the
extraocular muscles.
Thyroid eye disease can
cause double vision.
If there's a retroorbital
mass, meaning
the mass within the
orbit or behind the
eyeball, that can
also cause proptosis
and basically squish
some of the extraocular
muscles and cause
strabismus as well.
And something called
a carotid cabinous
fistula can also
cause a similar
presentation, which we
see on the bottom right
hand image where
there's a fistula
between those two
vascular structures and
it's pushing the
eyeball forward and
causing not only
proptosis, but strabismus
as well, where the
eye can't come in.
Systemic disease
can also cause eye
problems. So like we
talked about with the
uveitis, lots of
autoimmune diseases are
associated with
inflammation in the eye.
Hepatitis C and
******** are less common
causes, but we can
see that as well.
What we see here on
the bottom is severe
thinning of the cornea
that can occur in
autoimmune disease. This
can happen actually in
rheumatoid arthritis,
where we see a really,
really severe thinning
of the cornea, and
these patients may
need really specialized
contact lenses, or they
may require a large
corneal scleral graft.
Wilson's disease,
which you may or may
not be familiar with,
can also present with
something called a
sunflower cataract.
Other systemic diseases
with ocular findings,
HIV retinopathy
can look a lot like
diabetic retinopathy,
where you get some
bleeding, and you may
have some blockages
of blood vessels in
the back of the eye.
Tuberculosis
retinitis can look
horrible. It causes
a lot of damage to
the retinal tissue
in the back of
the eye, as well
as the vasculature.
Leukemia can actually
cause damage to the
back of the eye as
well, where you may
actually see some
bleeding there too. And
of course, we saw the
images of the melanoma
causing a retinal
detachment earlier.
Diabetic retinopathy
is a huge problem that
we worry about as
ophthalmologists and general
practitioners. Up to
80% of patients with
diabetes develop this
after 20 years of the
diagnosis, and it's
the leading cause of
blindness in patients
aged 20 to 64 years old.
So these patients may
have very, very small
findings where
there's maybe a small
microaneurysm that you
see on exam, or you might
see exudates, which
are these shiny goldish
findings in the picture
here. You may see
that there's a blockage
of a blood vessel
in the back of the
eye. You may see that
there's bleeding into
the vitreous cavity. you
may see that there's
a retinal detachment.
This is a true
vasculopathy. Just like the
small vessels going
to the kidneys are
damaged in uncontrolled
diabetes, the same
thing can happen in
the eye. The goal here
is to reduce vision
loss. So standard
of care is make sure
that the blood sugar
is under control. And
then usually a retina
surgeon will treat via
laser or injections
and sometimes
vitrectomy surgery, the
eye, depending on how
severe the case is.
But the underlying
treatment
is glycemic control.
So we went through
a lot of different
things here.
Please do reach out
to me if you have
any questions.
There are many, many
ocular diseases and
systemic conditions
that affect the
eye. A good history
and physical is key.
You want to always check
vision or eye pressure
if possible and
refer when necessary.
And, you know, just
thinking back to what I
would focus on in terms
of your exams, both
in school and then
going forward for your
boards and whether or not
you go into ophthalmology
or PEDS or OBGYN,
you know, things to
know about certainly
cornea, the cataracts.
You want to be able
to identify on an exam
what acute angle closure
glaucoma looks like,
especially for those
of us seeing older
patients. we want to
be aware of temporal
arteritis. We certainly
want to be aware of the
signs and symptoms of
retinal detachments.
And maybe for those
of us going into
internal medicine and
infectious disease,
****** zoster
ophthalmic is a good
one to be aware of.
But again, please
don't hesitate to
reach out to me
if you have any
questions or concerns.
Thank you.